hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday November 13 2017 what's going on
how I yeah what's going on I am in New
York City
well butter to the dough to dote oh
that's actually Hollywood what the [ __ ]
am I thinking it's not a New York song
right but but a little did it did it it
that's Hollywood right that's a New York
song start spreading the news right I
don't [ __ ] know I'm all over the map
here I'm winding down this trip I just
wrapped up my acting gig on Front Rada I
want to thank everybody that that
allowed me to be on that movie I had
such a great time I met so many great
people on that shoot and the last night
of the shoot I actually got to do a
scene with the star of the movie Hugh
Jackman and I can't even tell you how
great that experience was he might he
might be then not one of the nicest guys
I've ever met in my life
totally big guy - he's like six four or
something big guy totally cool nicest
[ __ ] dude whatever then you start
doing the scene right and it's his
character in the sink was getting was
getting mad and like frustrated with
Dustin and he went into that Wolverine
thing a little bit I was just like Jesus
Christ I would not [ __ ] with this guy
just an amazing amazing actor and I was
the coolest thing like on the last night
we had like two things to shoot like one
quick thing in a car and then the whole
rest of the thing was us you know like
me and two other actors and Hugh Jackman
and it was just like it was yeah we shot
that the whole night and it was one of
those things we like I wouldn't really
care if we continued shooting this scene
tomorrow I'm having so much fun you know
I assure I like to run when I act and
this scene involves me running into
running before I didn't I delivered the
my lines or whatever and I found that I
really liked that I was just like wow no
wonder I always liked William Shatner
and TJ hookah I know I've talked about
this before but if you ever watched TJ
Hooker I don't think in the history of
television
they ever they ever made an actor run
farther than they made William Shatner
who was well into his 50s by then they
would just have like this the master
shot of the scene and I want to get all
on Hollywood here Runyon but the master
is just when you go to shoot the scene
is you're just it's a wide shot and
you're capturing every character in it
or you're establishing the place I know
the setting I have no [ __ ] I think
that's what it is right they would just
they would just be standing on the other
side of a wharf a runway like Williams
shot and he chased after planes and they
would just start and he would come
running around the corner and he would
always be like 70 yards away and they'd
be playing this [ __ ] music with the
bongos in the background and you would
watch him just full speed running a man
in his 50s alright and this is like the
80s so no guys stretched unless you were
unlike the you know you had to be like
in the Olympics even then if you watch
like the old NFL Films the way that they
would stretch you know what I mean they
weren't doing like any just sort of you
know doing a forward bend none of that
yoga [ __ ] it was like touching toes
touch your hips touch your shoulders do
a jumping jack come back down or
whatever the [ __ ] they would do great
for that type of stuff running in cop
shoes full speed for a good 80 yards
there's actually a great YouTube video
that I think I posted before of wheelie
of TJ Hooker running so anyways I had
the I had the best time and did the
perfect amount of time on the movie cuz
right when it ended I came right here to
New York and then I'm gonna go back in
the rest of my year other than like two
Road gigs I am done and I'm gonna get to
spend this ridiculous amount of quality
time
with my wife and daughter and I can't
wait I'm totally getting into the
Christmas spirit this year not to the
point of sacrificing Thanksgiving you
know I might even put up a couple of
little like cutout turkeys in my house I
ate out Thanksgiving just gets passed
over you know what I mean gets passed
over like a I don't know like a person
that should have got the job but didn't
right
but I'm totally getting into it and I am
I'm still sober
it was it was 84 days on Thursday so 85
86 87 88 everett lindros 88 Lynn Swann
right wasn't he 88 yeah
88 days not boozing and I think I'm
gonna go for the hundred I don't know
you know I think I will be let's see
I'll be 91 on Thursday a week from
Thursday it'll be 98 and then it'll be
Thanksgiving and what I'm not gonna have
a little brandy and my eggnog that I'm
big with the brandy on the eggnog you
know that's what I would have added to
the great Opie and Anthony bit the
eggnog Opie Anthony little Jimmy right
do you think those guys will ever get
back together do like a reunion tour
they should have like a one-off you
don't like a torreón like the police got
back together they should do that with
great radio shows where everybody
eventually you know just got sick of
each other and went the other way but
the fans are still sitting there like
come on man just do one more tour man
they should all get together you know I
think it'll have if Guns and Roses can
get back together right I don't [ __ ]
know anyways plowing ahead yeah I'm
totally gonna get into the holidays and
I don't know I don't know about the
drinking thing I think I'm done for a
while like I said I want to go sting in
my 50s I'm turning 50 in June and I want
to make sure
[Music]
I don't know that's a critical [ __ ]
decade right that's that one they may
you know people like [ __ ] die in
their 50s so I got a you just that's
when people just start dying I mean
people who I've oh god I've already lost
like I've lost count how many [ __ ]
friends I actually I have a list on my
phone so I don't forget all the comics
that I've known that have died by the
way all men all men out of the 25
they're all men so all these women out
there like you don't understand how
difficult it is to be a woman it's like
lady I got 25 dead friends they're all
guys okay I don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on with us but whatever you guys
are there's something that you guys
something in your life is easier I know
in this age of feminism where it just
has to be everything is so [ __ ] much
harder for a woman
there is one easy thing one easier thing
for a woman and it really is the most
important thing and that is stayin alive
I would have [ __ ] it's my phone I got em
all like I got and I'm I'm probably
gonna forget a few people all right
let's see here these are all the [ __ ]
people that I knew that are gone here
all right
it all started with Mitch Hedberg in
like March I think at 2005 Mitch Hedberg
Freddy Soto Mitch Mulaney Robert
Schimmel Bernie Mac Dave Fitzgerald
Kevin Knox Bob side Bell Bob Lazar ahthe
rich Zeisler otto from Otto and George
greg Giraldo Patrice O'Neal Todd Lynn
Sam Brown Charlie Murphy Scott Kennedy
John Pinette Richard Jeni Mike deceased
a--they Stefano
Ralphie May and Pete coming those are
all the people that I knew really well
or worked with as a comedian that have
all died since 2005 separate Dave
Fitzgerald he died earlier he died in
like 2001 he was a Boston comic and I
probably forgot a few people
you know club owners Manny Dorman Lucien
hope and then I have like let's see high
school kids that I went to school with
one two three four five six seven eight
all guys [ __ ] unbelievable you just
don't understand sometimes what it's
like to be I know I absolutely
I'm sure it's [ __ ] much more
difficult in a lot of ways but I'll tell
you the most important way staying alive
let's not forget that anyways so I did
the the new West Side comedy club and it
was I just the perfect layout and I also
love to it's right around the corner
from the The Beacon Theatre so I've
gotten to play there a couple of times
but what I also love is if I was a young
comedian starting out it's really like
this motivational thing where you walk
out and then you walk around the corner
and there's the Beacon Theater and you
can kind of be thinking you know someday
maybe I'll be able to play that place
that's the type of [ __ ] that used to get
me used to get me motivated when I was
starting out although I don't know about
playing theaters I think was just seeing
Caroline's comedy club because when I
was starting out like nobody played
theatres it was like Cosby played
theatres George Carlin like you had to
be like a legend Joan Rivers those
people played like theaters and you know
for most comedians when I started I
think it was the dream was to just sell
out clubs the dream was to sell out
clubs and to get a sitcom built around
your act that was the dream and then
somewhere along the line it switched and
a lot of people talk about you know
social media and blah blah and all that
I think the biggest thing that is
created one of the big things that
people forget as far as like how all of
these comedians now are
are big enough of a draw to play
theaters I think one of the best things
that happened for comedians
that nobody brings up is Napster an
online file-sharing air-quote sharing of
music which was really stealing music
that completely destroyed the music
business and their ability to make stars
you're my virgin records remember you
were going in they had that little CD
listening thing and they had like the
top ten of the top 20 CDs and they'd
always be like a new band in there it's
like they were feeding you know bringing
new people in and once Napster came out
and it was the LimeWire and all of that
[ __ ] and then iTunes and all of that
what happened was Oh am I gonna use this
term there was an Arrested Development
of new like when you look at like the
amount of bands that broke through in
like the last ten years that was
suddenly able to sell out arenas it's
like a handful of bands or people like
Lady Gaga Bruno Mars was that twenty one
pilots as very few that got that big at
least not as much as as they used to I
feel my might be completely wrong in
this but if I'm if I'm not mistaken
there was like like the MTV music or had
like the five the same five artists for
a long time were with a few new ones but
like like jay-z Kanye and like I don't
know I'm not so good with all the
youngest people's stuff but they stuck
around forever at those Music Awards
because there was not these new people
coming in usually for somebody to stick
around in a music award for over ten
years I feel like there was only a
couple of bands that could do it but
they had to keep those people from ten
years previous because they all got
knocked out and then I'm gonna get to a
point here so everything became a quick
little [ __ ] I don't want to pay for
it online and I think and everybody went
online either wanted to [ __ ]
watch someone do something incredible on
a skateboard some x-games [ __ ] or you
wanted to watch people fail and you
wanted to laugh and I feel like stand-up
comedy fit into that setup punch setup
punch it was quick they made you laugh
you [ __ ] moved on and then I think
comedians slid into all of these theater
gigs that we're all these bands would
have been playing I'm not talking arenas
I just mean like like theatres I might
be wrong on that one but I think if you
look at the graph as the music business
imploded comedy went through the [ __ ]
roof then also with technology our comic
comics could just keep putting out these
specials and then Netflix was another
big thing but everybody talks about that
but nobody seems I don't know I think
the music business completely imploding
also helped out stand-up it created a
void I don't know you like that you like
me discussing the feat the ins and outs
of ticket sales and stand-up comedy so
anyway so I was working at the Westside
comedy club you got to go there some old
friends of mine open the place up that's
why I did it I had the best time or what
was really cool is isn't mostly you know
podcast listeners so I could say
whatever the [ __ ] I thought essentially
in these times you know what I mean
everything that's going on you know I
heard like those [ __ ] people were
going down to the Comedy Cellar and then
writing down what other comics were
saying about louis c.k and all of that
type of stuff was just it's just so
[ __ ] it's such a crazy time right now
and you know I don't know I love louis
c.k and that was really obviously just a
[ __ ] hard thing to see happened to
somebody and he was definitely a hundred
percent wrong I'll just say that he was
on a percent wrong he did own up to it
and I think he will definitely be back I
will say that and I also knew a couple
of the women that he did this [ __ ] to
and I just felt bad for everybody it's
just [ __ ] terrible and I don't know I
don't know
I don't know what else you see you say
about it I feel like I'm in a divorce
where you know both the mom and the dad
you need is you got to like pick a
[ __ ] side here you know I don't know
all I think there's just this new thing
though is like like the level of
witch-hunt that happened when the Loess
thing came out like the amount of
[ __ ] people that they went after was
just [ __ ] it was like six degrees of
Louise dick you know to the point even
the [ __ ] Huffington Post was even
trying to like you know list people that
clients of the same manager that he had
and stuff who by the way is one of the
great people I've ever met in life I
stand by my [ __ ] manager and I'm
never firing the guy I've been with this
guy since 2006 Dave Beck he's one of the
great people that I've met in this
business I love that guy I still have
him over my house for [ __ ] dinner
watching everybody just oh I think I
remembered this happening 15 [ __ ]
years ago and then watching everybody
try to burn down this guy's life it's
just [ __ ] protects people this is
America
you remember due process like the whole
thing is just like it's [ __ ] insane I
would be surprised if they're going
after louis ck's mailman saying if you
deliver his mail get part of the problem
you know and it doesn't seem to be like
there's any sort of like you know in the
judicial system where there's like if
you steal a bike you get this sentence
if you rob a bank you get this if you
kill somebody if you kill a whole bunch
of people all the way up to the death
penalty yeah this kind of seems like
it's become it doesn't make a difference
if it's sexual misconduct all the way to
sexual assault slash rape you know
you're getting the exact same like level
of punishment so that's only my question
okay out of all of this because he was
definitely wrong obviously I mean he's
all obvious [ __ ] that I'm saying but
does the punishment match the crime
because you know sexual misconduct
I mean you talk of sexual misconduct
like I I know I would I don't know how
many podcast I would have to do
to tell you all the stories of sexual
misconduct with just women as a stand-up
comedian who used to go out after his
shows selling his posters and all and
taking pictures with you just the
[ __ ] women okay and I'll tell you it
was never any of the young once it was
on always these middle-aged [ __ ]
women couple glasses of red wine Oh God
and they come at you with their love of
boom energy and you'd be like oh no here
we go you know that's my advice young
male comics out there
young female comics is plenty of
information out there for you now about
watching out for creepy guys but I don't
think there's anything out there for
young male comics I will tell you this
okay if you're going to go out and meet
a crowd afterwards when middle-aged
women you can tell they've had too much
wine beyond the fact that they're sort
of teetering or in their high-heeled
shoes with their old feet sticking out
of them you just look for the gray teeth
alright and a little bit too much makeup
and then they're you know they got the
girls out a little bit just [ __ ]
watch yourself okay cuz that's the
that's the old cheerleader who is not
aging well and is freaking out that guys
don't you know find her attractive
anymore
and I'm telling you they're gonna come
up to you dick you know cover your junk
that's all of us say dude I had a woman
lick my neck one time and I'll tell you
worse than the touch of her tongue her
old ass disgusting wine breath tongue on
my [ __ ] neck worse than that was I
felt her breath right before the Eagle
landed I will uh oh gee oh and forget
about gay guys Jesus Christ I can't do
another half podcast on that one before
just talking about sexual misconduct I
always wanted to rub your chest the [ __ ]
did you just do I mean what time it is
the thing about a guy when it happens to
a guy is
funny just for the simple fact that you
know generally speaking you can
overpower whoever the [ __ ] is coming at
you I'm not I'm not a little boy so I
get why nobody gives a [ __ ] when this
happens to a guy I get it I remember I
was taking this absolutely lovely woman
beautiful woman she danced on Broadway
she was such a sweetheart
I loved it to death and I completely
[ __ ] it up because I was an angry
young man so I'm sorry to her right so
she was dancing in this thing called
Broadway bears which was like they used
to do this thing to raise money it was
like a burlesque show so it wasn't like
this creepy titty bar thing it was just
you know if you ever go to a burlesque
show which my wife took me to one to see
that Dita Von Teese I was just like are
you [ __ ] kidding me
she's gonna take me down here to go to
go see basically go to a rated pg-13
strip club I have the coolest wife ever
and then I got down there and I think I
was the only straight guy there and it
was like mostly gay guys right and
that's what this Broadway bares thing
wasn't it wasn't like the creepy Hooters
vibe so it's actually better if there's
a bunch of gay dudes there cuz I always
did that whole like hooters strip clubs
titty bars and all that [ __ ] it's just
like that's something that's like
fascinating when you're like in your 20s
I think and then somewhere you know if
you're progressing if you're maturing at
some point it just becomes gross or at
the very least like this is [ __ ]
stupid you know I want to go out and get
laid I'm gonna sit here looking at naked
women who aren't gonna [ __ ] me you know
this is stupid while losing a ton of
money paying for watered-down drinks
what now I don't want to eat in here
you're in the sex industry get away from
me I want to order some food right so I
go down to this Broadway bares thing
right and you know there's all these
[ __ ] layers there's all these smokin
hot women doing their dances and stuff
and then there's all these shredded
dudes so all the gay guys that go nuts
about the dudes
and I'm looking at all these women going
like oh my god right [ __ ] dancer legs
they were incredible right oh by the way
they also were really talented all right
so the [ __ ] show ends and I waiting
for my girlfriend at the time to come
out and this [ __ ] I don't know it
this guy came up and just smacked me on
the ass and it wasn't like like it was
like if you were playing football it was
good game but at that place it wasn't
this guy wanted to [ __ ] hook up me
dude he hit me so hard like I almost
[ __ ] got whiplash and I [ __ ]
turned around and I can't say what I
said to the guy but I made it clear to
him that I wasn't gay and I'll never
forget he just like put his hands up and
was like backing away and everybody put
his hands up the dude at these [ __ ]
guns and I was just like you know I
don't know what this guy's thinking
right now but if he wanted to do
something I don't know if there's
anything I could do about it
his big hairy gay arms just going out oh
I'm sorry I just [ __ ] know you didn't
even talk like that I'm doing like the
hacky gay voice he had just like a
regular dude voice and I'll do I got it
zillion of those [ __ ] zillion of
those [ __ ] stories if we're talking
sexual misconduct here and and you know
what's funny is the reason I stopped
going out after my shows wasn't all of
those [ __ ] witches of eastwick drunk
[ __ ] coming up to me doing god knows
what
right just crossing all kinds of [ __ ]
lines like you literally like you're a
cartoon character what made me finally
stop was that time the guy went to take
the camera out to take the picture of
his girlfriend a wife and a loaded
9-millimeter felon
crowd and it was right on the ground and
I should have kicked it away you know
all the episodes are sassy and Hutch I
watched I didn't I just froze I pointed
at the gun I went dude what the [ __ ] and
I let him
bend down and pick it up and I just
stood there I've never felt more white
in my life you know what I mean just
classic cul-de-sac like hey Frank do I
believe you dropped your pistol thanks
Bill
blows my [ __ ] brains out oh you hear
that that's my alarm I got up a little
early so anyways people I think it's a
great thing that all of this stuff is
coming out because there's no way that
women should have to be tolerating this
they've tolerated it way too long but
can we stop short here of like then
trying to literally destroy everybody
around the [ __ ] person over social
media and no burden of proof whatsoever
these are like real people that you're
going after okay you know these people
that are around these people that have
done horrible things they have wives
they have kids they have families they
have mortgages you know and just to just
[ __ ] just willy nilly Oh somebody's
just said this on Twitter it has to be
true and just pile on and blow on the
ashes and try to turn it into [ __ ] a
[ __ ] inferno as is also not right
okay and I feel really bad for my
manager and what the hell he's going
through right now I really do and I'm
not gonna be one of these [ __ ] people
and I hate how there's this whole
[ __ ] day and it don't say anything
man it's not worth it don't say things
so I'm just gonna leave this guy who's
been a friend to me for [ __ ] 11 years
guided me through my career my career
went through the [ __ ] stratosphere
with this guy I'm just gonna leave him
twisting in the wind go [ __ ] yourself
Dave Beck he's a great guy anyways
plowing ahead what do we got here but
Papa Papa let's read a little bit of no
I you know what I missed I missed the I
missed the Formula One race and it
sounded like it was amazing every day I
don't know how Lewis Hamilton ended up
starting in last place but he worked his
way all the way up to first which I have
never seen somebody must have crashed
because I don't know the way max
Verstappen was running during the last
race once somebody gets out in front you
know when they're driving through the
clean air there what a little thing I
know about aerodynamics and racing no
one can never catch him so they must
have had a brilliant strategy PLAs like
slashed somebody else that was plus plus
and slash plash somebody's car must have
broken down or there must have been an
accident or something I have no idea but
uh can somebody sign oh you guys have
sent me this link before can somebody
try and find or send me the link to
where where I can rewatch the races the
replay of them because Brazil's a
grandma did you see [ __ ] the
mercedes-benz team got robbed at
gunpoint
Lewis Hamilton wasn't there and but his
quote was basic this happens every time
we come down here how bad is that for
tourism in Brazil you know what I mean
every time we come down here the
Illuminati's sport gets [ __ ] robbed
can we do something about security you
know thank God like you know if I was
like the president of Brazil I actually
wouldn't be too nervous because Brazil
has arguably the most beautiful women in
the world down there you know what I
mean and that will keep people coming
despite the fact that even the
mercedes-benz Formula One team gets
robbed at gunpoint and they weren't
there on vacation they came down there
with the entire sport and somebody's
still finally got through I guess when
you got a pistol you don't really need a
laminate do you can we see your
credentials yeah yeah right here buddy
okay
Lewis Hamilton's over there and I
believe he still has his diamond earring
it have at it
all right let's read let's read some
some advertising here for this week's
aathi everybody saw the-- everyone at
some point has which wished
just have a beer wine or liquor
delivered
well someone finally decided to do
something about it next police mention
all the talking points below introducing
saathi the the alcohol delivery app
saucy delivers your favorite wine beer
liquor right - you do and no more no
more demand it's uber for alcohol now if
you're in Los Angeles now if you're in
Los Angeles San Francisco Chicago San
Diego or Sacramento your saucy order
will arrive at your door in 30 minutes
or less ready to drink for the rest of
us
saucy will deliver beer wine and liquor
to your door in two days or less
nationwide there are no order minimums
no delivery fees no running to the store
see if you got a party coming up right
your parents are going out of town right
you're gonna have a gig you're gonna
have a blowout right you can call these
people up if you got the saucy app you
got a fully stocked bar right on your
phone and for a limited time you can get
$15 off when you download the saucy app
and enter their promo code BRR that
saucy app spelled saucy sauc ey and
enter promo code BIR for $15 off get the
saucy app today and use promo code burn
oh look who's back everybody look who's
back boo biondi's biondi's why did you
lick my neck - dududu biondi's me undies
but i'ma get part of them a guy so what
the heck it doesn't [ __ ] count if you
have a dick so if you grabbed my junk
really quick you're not going to jail
and you're all your [ __ ] will still be
on [ __ ] HBO ba ba ba ba boo boo
alright let me tell you about me undies
the only underwear this is the only one
to wear that makes for an amazing gift
feel free to improvise Jesus Christ soft
that's what they just wrote there talk
about why you love me undies you know I
love me undies because I love singing
this song
that's why plus I evidently they're also
soft flexible waistband three times
softer than cotton cotton just takes a
beating during these these these [ __ ]
you know
these reeds they're always getting
trashed I'm waiting for them to have
like an answer sunk you know naturally
sustainable sourced fiber me undies has
made me and ease made underwear the
perfect gift that everyone is going to
love you for it's a great stocking
stuffer
it's a goddamn holiday miracle this year
don't give underwear give me undies this
holiday season to get your exclusive 20%
off the softest underwear and socks you
will ever wear free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee
go to my undies comm slash bird that's
my undies comm slash / alright Dollar
Shave Club as soon as I heard Dollar
Shave Club had stuff other than their
razors I was sold evidently why do they
always try to write what I'm thinking
alright I actually think that they're
really smart like why stop there they
get it guys want a [ __ ] shower and shave
and they're giving them everything to do
it but with it right at the store there
are too many options and you can't tell
the difference between any of them then
if you have any question the clerk
usually doesn't know the difference
either or can't really help you since
they are not experts on products just
like their razors everything is super
high quality and left me looking and
feeling amazing evidently from premium
ingredients to sophisticated sense you
know like before you put it on everybody
thinks you're a [ __ ] then all of a
sudden you put on their [ __ ] body
spray though did you go to grad school
Dollar Shave Club is changing the games
that is set to new members for only $5
the starter set features their executive
razor and three trial size versions of
their most popular products that help
you stay fresh and clean in your first
box you receive their shave butter body
wash in one wipe cherries butt wipes oh
sorry you will also receive their
executive razor which includes their
premium weighty handle and focused set
of cartridges by the way when you get a
razor that has a weighty handle do not
pull it down and drag it across your
face okay you
just let it you just lightly hold it and
you let gravity pull it down across your
face that's that's the way you do it all
right trust me if you do it the other
way you're gonna cut your face if you do
it the way I just said you're gonna get
the smoothest shave you ever had in your
life after the first box replacement
cartridges are sent for only a few bucks
a month this offer is exclusively
available at dollarshaveclub.com slash
bar this dollarshaveclub.com / / and if
you want a great gift give them Dollar
Shave Club they've got a super simple
gift membership and eat Gift Cards
Dollar Shave club's high quality
products will have you covered from face
cheeks to butt cheeks there is no better
time to try the club oh and stamps calm
everybody lastly but certainly not least
Lee stamps saves you time and money
which you can use to grow your business
you can mail any letter in any package
just using your computer or printer and
the mailman comes and picks it up avoid
the hassle man of the post office and
mail everything from Post Office some
postcards to envelopes to packages
domestic or international create your
stamps account in minutes online with no
equipment to lease and no long term
commitments click print mail and you're
done unlike the post office stamps com
never closes print postage for letters
or packages at your own convenience 24/7
it's convenient it's easy its reliable
its flex its flexible right just like
that cool check up the street that
doesn't want to be in a relationship I
use stamps calm because anytime I send
out my [ __ ] posters you know and I
want to go out there and be I have some
sexual misconduct with some women who
are far too old to be acting in that way
I send him out from stamps calm dude
I've actually been telling his story of
by the letter of the law something that
happened to me last year which was
sexual assault which was by a woman but
it's a lady so no one gives a [ __ ] I
come out and see my [ __ ] stand-up set
there you go I'm teasing sexual assault
here I'm just turning it into a bit yeah
and it's a really funny [ __ ] story
but by the letter of the law it is
sexual assault you know and where's my
15 minutes of fame and right now you too
can enjoy stamps.com service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale
without a long long term commitments go
to stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in BER
that stamps comm stamps comm never go to
the post office again alright what are
we up to you alright 35 minutes alright
so the one of the other two reasons why
I'm here in New York okay three reasons
I did the westside comedy club BAM on
Saturday night I did Michael J Fox is
charity
the the Fox foundation I did a benefit
for them one of the coolest gigs I've
ever got to do in my life I I show up
right first of all it's Michael J Fox
right I mean that guy's comedic timing
you know like when they say somebody has
like perfect pitch when they go to sing
or whatever I always felt like you know
grew up watching him on family ties and
of course all the Back to the Future
movies and I just his timing was just
like was impeccable right and it makes
it real look really easy but just as a
fan of comedy and everything I always
loved the guy so I realized I was going
to get to meet him and I show up to the
gig and I'm always nervous whenever I
have to do a benefit because it's you
know it's a benefit people gonna be in
this you know they're gonna be in a
certain mindset or it's just like you
know wow I'm really lucky that you know
I'm healthy I have my family blah blah
blah blah blah and other these other
people are going through this really
difficult thing there's no there's a
sense of like guilt that you feel just
all of that type it just puts the crowd
in a certain mood where then all of a
sudden they go from laughing to
everything that you say it's just like
oh
boo you know those are the sounds I
usually hear at benefits so I was I'm
always a little apprehensive and in my
head I'm sitting there going like all
right how can i navigate this situation
because there's what I want to talk
about and then there's what I should
talk about just to get through this
right so I show up in the one of the
first people I saw was Eugene Mirman who
hadn't seen in a while and I was so
relieved to see another comedian I was
just like out thank God so we both would
just sort of laugh and talking about how
all right it's a benefit I always just
what's gonna happen how is this one
gonna go down hopefully this is going to
be good and as I was talking to him I
heard this amazing band plane in the
background was okay that kid sounded so
good I'm like is that live that's unreal
but we were back in the green room I was
like I got to check them out and raise I
went to go out this like guy comes
walking by it goes eight Bilborough you
don't eat he's like yeah you know I you
know I've seen your stuff man you're
funny
I said ah thanks a lot I appreciate it I
got look at you you're dressed all sharp
I'm like a you going up tonight he goes
yeah I go what do you do
you're comedian he goes die guys I play
a little guitar you know I love
musicians I'm like holy [ __ ] man you
playing a band that's [ __ ] great
right turned out that guy was Brad
Paisley I'm old I don't know who the
kids are right I have no [ __ ] idea he
went on in the end and was one of the
greatest entertainers I've seen in a
long [ __ ] time absolutely a little
guitar right shreds
absolutely shreds on guitar amazing
voice I said to him after because I felt
like an [ __ ] that I didn't know who
he was but I'm also I'm old you know I
may be 50 next year right I love and I'm
loving turning 50 now this is when you
start to have excuses I'm 50 I don't
know things I said to him I see you know
I love about you country guys all you
guys ki can play you know I'm not into
all the country music but they can
[ __ ] play and they can sing and it
reminds me of hair metal as much as
people trash me for list of that those
guys could play and they could sing they
could they could do it live well do it
live [ __ ] right so anyways I'm here
in all this Bay
and so I go I gotta go check these guys
out right after like the third song I
heard so I go to walk out there to see
the to see the band playing and I looked
at and I'm looking at the drummer this
is giant like you know banquet room and
I'm just looking at the drummer and I
just [ __ ] staring at him for like
five seconds in disbelief and I look at
the woman next to me who was working for
the foundation I was like is that Steve
Jordan she goes yeah he's like really
good I'm like really good he's one of
the greatest [ __ ] drummers of all
time this is like a bucket list for me
to ever see this guy play live I can't
believe it my jaw was on the ground like
you gotta understand like I I've been
listening to Steve Jordan since like I
guess when I first started watching
Letterman and I didn't even realize at
that point that he played on those Blues
Brothers albums and I discovered those I
even bought the second Blues Brothers
album made in America then nobody bought
I have all of that [ __ ] all of his Keith
Richards expensive wine oh [ __ ] I
watched him on the let with the
Letterman Band I go on YouTube there's a
fusion album that he put out what the
[ __ ] was the name of that band that you
can't I can't find the album anywhere
where he's really young playing on on
that one way busier than he he plays on
a lot of other stuff right through all
the John Mayer stuff and I was always
thinking okay when John Mayer comes to
town with his trio I'm definitely gonna
go see that and I finally get to see
Steve Jordan playing live
you know switching out the snares and
all of that that hold all that hope it's
his whole thing that he does that it's
just so incredible but every time John
Mayer would come to LA I would always be
on the road and I'd always miss it so I
actually got to see him play and so
anyways I'm sitting there and at the
banquet thing and I meet Michael J Fox
and he's just like the nicest guy ever
him and his wife just a couple of
sweethearts you know I'm just one of
those amazing couples too you know
both good-looking people and then they
form when they get together they form an
even more amazing person you know and
I'm sitting there and like I'm literally
nervous like I'm a brand new comic
whenever
when I do benefits I get like that
nervous cuz like I've had some that have
not gone well I've done some Christmas
part it's the reason why I don't do
Christmas parties
I don't do private gigs you know which
are basically rich people or rich
companies or something get together and
they will literally hire anyone from
like [ __ ] you two all the way down to
some no-name comic like I was back when
I used to do those [ __ ] things and
you would go out there and nobody would
know that there was a show and they did
my last one I did like they had me go up
it was in like a restaurant these people
had rented out the restaurant and
everybody was eating and talking and I
went up there and I was no one was
listening and I got defensive
so my already angry material back then
was coming off even angrier and people
just literally stopped eating we're just
sort of staring down at their plates and
I tried every trick that I knew in the
book to turn it around and I couldn't do
it and I just [ __ ] bombed I ruined
their dinner I ruined then at least that
part of it and I just walked out of
there with my agent at the time and god
bless him he had to listen to me walk 12
blocks with him with absolutely absolute
Tourette's just going like I am never
[ __ ] doing one of those [ __ ]
things again who da [ __ ] brings somebody
up when everybody's [ __ ] eating like
I did that I was going Casey Kasem and
I'm supposed to go in and talk about a
[ __ ] dog dying right I went into that
mode you know but by the end after 12
blocks I by the end of it we were both
laughing and I was just like should we
given that money back you know that was
like [ __ ] I feel bad this is a real
reason why I was flipping up you know I
was embarrassed and then I also felt
like I stole money cuz I just wasn't
though I wasn't the guy for that gig it
should have been like somebody like
who was happy with themselves alright so
anyways let's get on with the know if
I'll finish telling the story so anyways
fortunately the great Denis Leary was
was hosting this event and he went up
and immediately turned it into a comedy
show you know he was up there doing what
he does and he dropped you know couple
of f-bombs and then I with every joke he
told I got more and more and more and
more relaxed and I was like I thank God
and then I went up on stage and I just I
just [ __ ] went off and told all these
I just I don't know I I did all those
stories telling all those [ __ ] stories
of all this [ __ ] that women have done to
me and at first people didn't want to
laugh and then they just started laughs
cuz you know sexual misconduct yeah like
I said it to a guy I'm and I'm agreeing
with this it's kind of funny it's not
right but it it is it's funny and at
first they were like what the [ __ ] and
then they just sort of went with it and
then all the rest of my [ __ ] just flowed
and I ended up having one of my favorite
sets I've had in such a long time and
then in the end I got to watch this new
great musician that I did wasn't aware
of Brad Paisley playing with Steve
Jordan's band and and then in the end
they brought Michael J Fox out and they
all played Johnny be good I mean it was
just it wasn't I was just standing there
like going
how the [ __ ] is this my life was amazing
and I just sent a patent and it just
turned out it was also the New York
Comedy Festival so all these guys were
in town I got to run into Brant Brian
Regan who just played Carnegie Hall
hanging out with him I just had like the
best I had the best [ __ ] night and
and the great New York run here
continues where tomorrow I'm gonna be on
inside the NFL I don't know what I'm
gonna be talking about God knows I
haven't watched nearly as much NFL
football as I would have liked this year
I just got so busy with the cartoon and
my little acting gig there Oh bill what
do you think you're an actor now
everyone
while I am alright my screen went dark
here let's type in the [ __ ] password
the password alright let's let's read
some of your questions here alright not
enough women or gays at the cellar table
oh boy here we go
Oh red dick Billy call that controversy
and stand-up comedy he goes I was hoping
to get your take on an article I came
across on Facebook called tear down the
boys club that protected louis c.k
that's that witch-hunt thing that i'm
saying like we had [ __ ] meetings every
week alright what are we gonna do it
here same you know and how everybody
else ii that got evidently everybody
else on the other side the second that
Gawker article came out you know
immediately took a criminal justice
course and just became some gumshoe and
went out and bought a giant magnifying
glass and walked around looking for
clues alright it's written by a gay
comic who figures basically going after
Louie wasn't enough so he is trying to
go after his peers also yeah the witch
hunt the author cries about a certain
table at the Comedy Cellar were elite
comics like Chris Rock and Jerry
Seinfeld sit like when the table came
about by the way Jerry Seinfeld was
still doing Seinfeld you know what I
mean I don't know if they actually had a
place called the table when I first
started going to the Comedy Cellar there
wasn't a table the comics just went
upstairs and they sat all over the place
and I am convinced that the reason why
the table was started was because of
Patrice because Patrice was so loud and
so funny and he was just all over the
upstairs they were trying to somehow
contain him he was like Jordan you know
you're not gonna stop him let's just see
if we can contain him so I think they
just tried to get us all insid sitted
and one seated in one area so they could
at least be like okay sit down and fold
your [ __ ] hands and listen to the
teacher right
that's how I remember anyway so he goes
he also has never
even tried to perform at the cop at the
cellar himself it's kind of like a
fourth grader crying to the teacher
because the cool kids won't hang out
with him the article implies that by not
speaking up about it the sella comics
were somehow protecting Louie even
though they were just rumors until
recently also the owner of the cellar
where we [ __ ] scream with dr. ulsio
necessarily had some great things to say
in the comments here's a link to the
article and go [ __ ] yourself yeah I read
it and you know to be honest with you
considering this guy is also a fellow
comedian I feel bad that that was his
perception I feel filthy add that that
was his perception of what the table was
because you know the table was like I
didn't know how to explain it like that
was something like the level of pounding
that you had to take you had to go there
and just basically get ripped to shreds
and then what everybody at the table
wanted to do then it wasn't even it
wasn't doing it to just be mean it was
just I don't know it was just this
comedian thing so you'd sit down and
like you already would you sit down with
like whatever you were hung up about
with yourself and they would give
another 40 things about you physically
that you didn't even notice that you
should also be self-conscious about
however in the end all they wanted you
to do was come back at them and trash
them back and if you did you were in
regardless all right and there was some
epic [ __ ] back-and-forth sat that
table you know people definitely got mad
sometimes but uh the table wasn't like
what a lot of people who didn't go to it
think it was like this big bullying
thing it was also this amazing thing
where like I listened to Jewish people
and Arab comics going at it talking
about the Middle East I'd listen to
Patrice and you know manage woman their
debates Colin Quinn was there and if I
remember correctly
tough crowd came out of those
conversations at the table and if you
watched tough crowd and be these
comedians talking about these deep
issues while trashing each other and I
always felt this the table was inclusive
as long as you were willing you had to
he had to [ __ ] walk the gauntlet you
just had to [ __ ] do and you had to
survive it and then if you did you
actually became a better comedian
because once you got in at the table
then there was this thing you couldn't
not sit at the table you'd come in hey
Bill come and they wanted you to sit the
table because they wanted you to trash
you and then they also wanted you to
trash him back but you know I wasn't
even part of the elite crew I wasn't
funny enough I just wasn't like the the
the as far as this is just my my
perception of it was the table was
Patrice Norton Voss Keith Robinson Colin
Quinn and later on Kevin Hart I'm Kevin
Hart right and even he was sort of like
just like a rookie but he also made it
so fast he didn't have time to [ __ ]
stay there so those were that that was
like the Mount Rushmore of the table and
when you showed up and they were all
there and somebody had something on you
like that time you know I for 24 hours
said I would do stand-up on a bus on the
weight of a World Series game to get a
World Series ticket and I never even
ended up doing the gig I took a
headlining set pounding that is still
legendary they told the [ __ ] story on
Opie and Anthony I believe Kevin Hart
and them all told the story man I got
[ __ ] destroyed destroyed so this guy
like suggesting that it was all like
everybody was like there was this team
of people it wasn't it was [ __ ]
cannibalistic all right everything that
they said in open anthe was 100% true
except for the fact that I did the gig
because I didn't do the gig I actually
gave the gig to somebody else and I went
with the vawious silence I said I will
never
anybody that you did this gig because I
don't want you to go through what I just
went through I think the guy did the gig
actually might have said that he was the
one who did the gig all these years
later but I still I'm not saying [ __ ]
who it was so anyways once you got in at
the table then you would go downstairs
to go do your set and one night they
everybody the table be like you know
what we're watching your set tonight and
you'd be like aw [ __ ] and you would go
downstairs you'd go on stage and the
crowd couldn't see all these [ __ ]
[ __ ] comics I remember they'd all be
backlit standing in the hallway
Patrice's big dumb stupid-head and you'd
have to scho up there and like just
commit to your jokes as they were all
standing there making faces of disgust
heckling making noises and one time I
told the joke and it went good and as I
was telling the joke I had the nerve to
actually try to say something in a joke
and Patrice would just go just do that
[ __ ] noise and then they would all
crack up laughing then the crowd would
laugh like what the [ __ ] and get a sense
of like other comics are laughing at
this guy should we be laughing at him
and not respect him as a human being and
then you would just start bombing and
never forget I remember Kevin Hart went
down stairs and he went up as a 20 year
old comic and survived it and was barely
affected I mean I know and then looking
at all the stuff that he's doing now
like you really saw what he was made of
it was a great thing the cellar table is
not what this person perceived it to be
and I feel bad that that person because
having a fat gay guy comic there would
have been great there would've been a
whole other angle it was actually a
really inclusive thing it's just a lot
of people weren't tough enough to get
through it and that's the truth and it
took me like I said like a half dozen
attempts because I was not a mentally
strong person back then and but if you
see what came out of it Colin Quinn's
tough crowd that was one of the most
inclusive shows of all time as far as
like he gave almost like two-and-a-half
generations of stand-up comics a TV
credit a lot of them their first TV
credit
so I don't know and I don't know what
someone's gonna sit down and watch stuff
probably who's mainly white males will
blend all that [ __ ] [ __ ] so I don't
know there's no way to win this type of
stuff but I can tell you that I don't
agree with this person's perception of
it but I don't have any anger towards
that person for writing that if that's
what they think it was but it's a little
melodramatic burn the table down like
this these meetings going on and we're
all sitting there trying to hold back
his his career or whatever I mean I
don't I don't [ __ ] all I remember as
far as like trans comics I just
remembered there was I don't know what
the proper term was but there was a guy
who dressed like a woman who went on
stage and went by the name she went by
the name Sharon Needles and she used to
go up at the Boston comedy club and she
was [ __ ] hilarious and the last time
I looked her up I believe she was still
doing shows I think she just got out of
the stand-up scene but nobody I don't
knows no comics going Oh what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] person doing here like
this all comic all comedy is is if
you're [ __ ] funny other comics are
gonna laugh and you get their respect
and you're in you know everybody has a
different [ __ ] Road but everybody's
just sitting there going like just I
don't know what what they're it's
everybody's looking out their own head
and it becomes their experience is fact
in truth and anybody else's experience
is [ __ ] or something like that so
all I'm doing here is I'm telling my
side that's how I perceived it and I
just remember for the longest time like
we would I'm a one night we [ __ ] were
outside the Comedy Cellar we trashed
each other for so [ __ ] long and it
was so goddamn funny it was so late in
the night that this woman in an
apartment above the Comedy Cellar poured
water down on to us to get us to shut
the [ __ ] up
and going back you know like a lot of
moments like that in life I wish I could
have I wish I could have realized how
amazing that was during that time
because that as far as I was concerned
the table this table that this guy wants
to burn down that died the table died
when Manny died because you know he was
the creator of it and he was the one of
the great conversationalist that I ever
met
and he was so goddamn funny and and what
I love the bottom is he wasn't a
malicious guy as much as I got I used to
[ __ ] argue with that guy you know
what I mean I was just I was a young
angry man and I used to argue with that
guy and and he was always the next day
it was always over and I actually kind
of learned from him I learned from him
and Bobby Kelly how to squash an
argument where like how you be like the
next day just you know cuz I didn't grow
up in a family like that it was just
basic you didn't talk about it and then
you didn't talk for three days and then
[ __ ] four days later you say hey you
see the Celtics game you know so yeah it
was good good and then everything was
lingering those two people I learned how
to have a functional end to an argument
so yeah I don't know what that shit's
about but it's unfortunate that that
person feels that way about it but you
know everybody's entitled to their
opinion all right
Patrice a Billy Ray no fun after hearing
you along with so many other comics
University laud Patrice I finally
watched elephant in the room special
within minutes he had me in stitches
it's so easy to see why he was so
revered within the comedy community I
know you hold him both as a comedian as
a personal person in an incredibly high
regard I would love to hear some of your
insight into him I recently heard that
he was permanently banned from
performing at the stand in New York what
was that about
no he was never banned from the stand
the stand the stand came out or opened
right around when Patrice got sick he
wasn't banned from there anyways really
big fan of the show and would love to
see come to Australia against some
ya know Patrice Patrice was getting
banned from comedy clubs all the time
all the time but he was so [ __ ] good
they had to let him back in it reminds
me of when I read this this Miles Davis
book and he was talking about Charlie
Parker and when he would party too much
and pawn his horn and these clubs would
kick him out they'd eventually have to
[ __ ] bring him back in because he was
the best and Patrice was the best and
you know as much as he would drive him
nuts
you wanted him around you wanted him
around you gets just like the like the
comedy dropped by 40% even with all the
other comics still going there if he
wasn't there and just the fun and then
they also knew that if they banned him
that none of the comics were gonna hang
out at their clubs we were all gonna go
to where he was yes so then they would
let him back into the club then they
created the table that's that's how I
remember it
that's how I thought that they let's
we'll have him all these [ __ ]
lunatics just have him sit in the back
at the goddamn table so then we were
sitting down and it just you know it was
just a bunch of dogs and a [ __ ] pit
and then that's how the trash in and the
trashing was already happening I
remember one night you know after I took
the pounding for [ __ ] the bus gig
that I never even did I remember when
Bobby first shaved his head he came in
and I always respected him for this he
came in he had like a hat on and he sat
down right at the funk and the fat gay
guy comic here listen to this story he
didn't shy away from the table he
[ __ ] walked right in sat down took
his hat off and looked at everybody like
alright give it to me let's hear it and
[ __ ] everybody just was like a def
jam bit he took his hat off and
everybody just bought everyone the [ __ ]
he took this [ __ ] pounding and
everyone was getting him and he was just
sitting there taking it laughing and all
that type of stuff and I actually
thought he looked good with the shaved
head right
and what's-his-face
I said it I think it was SD SD finally
got him with one I think she said you
look like David Wells I think that
that's what she said and everybody
[ __ ] died laughing and Bobbie
literally just stood up and just walked
out and I remember thinking like you can
I didn't know you could do that I didn't
even walk out I saw Keith Robinson do
that one time too
we would trash in his clothes so [ __ ]
bad it was gay and he was trying to
fight back and he was just feeling that
wave was gonna crash over him he just
[ __ ] ran out the door got in his car
and drove home to Jersey we would be
kept texting him and calling him going
you can't do that you can't do that he's
like oh yeah well I just did stupid
[ __ ] hung up on its laughed and hung
up on us oh my god I remember that
[ __ ] time Patrice you know somehow we
found out he he was home on a Saturday
night
he just took like a night off and Jim
Norton [ __ ] came and said you know
what Patrice is right now he's at home
on a Saturday night and they all called
him up and on speakerphone
Patrice just picks up he's like hello
and Jim's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing home on a Saturday night you don't
have any gigs and Patrice just [ __ ]
roared laughing and we all over
speakerphone trashed him he was at home
getting trashed at the table and I just
remember him laughs he loved every
[ __ ] second of it it was it the table
is one of the great things ever so you
know don't listen that guy all right I
lied to my girlfriend all right I lied
to my girlfriend hey Bill I really could
use some advice right now I'm an
eighteen year old male and I have been
with this girl for seven months now I
really care about her and she makes me
truly happy about a year ago I used to
smoke weed and do some drugs other drugs
a lot I used to smoke about three or
four times a week but I quit a little
under a year ago my girlfriend is really
against drug use and has told me that
she would leave me if I ever did it
again well a couple months ago me and my
girl were kind of on a break not because
we don't want to be with each other but
because of some other [ __ ] going on in
our lives
alright that's pretty vague while we
were on this break I smoked some weed
with the buddy of mine
I really regret doing so because I know
how this is this means a lot to her
she is later asked me when was the last
time I did any drugs and I just lied and
told her the last time was when I told
her I quit I can't stop thinking about
this and I feel really bad about lying
to her but I am afraid she's going to
leave me or stop trusting me if I tell
her now since I had already lied about
it several times in the past alright
what do you do here just do what you
want to do alright if you can't live
with it I would tell her if not you mean
you [ __ ] smoke you took a hit off a
joint if you're not gonna but you're
really committed and you're not going to
do it again is it really worth putting
you and her through this it's kind of
hard for me to give you advice here cuz
I don't know what you broke up for I
mean you did it while you were broken up
it's not like you went out you bang some
other woman you just went out you just
took a hit and you didn't [ __ ] do it
again and you know that's it but at the
end of the day you know something if you
come clean and she still breaks up with
you over that then you know what [ __ ]
she kept she can't accept you it's not
like you went out you started using
heroin and you stole all the money out
of her [ __ ] purse she can't handle
one hit of a joint and then you feel bad
about it and you can't even lie to her
about it without feeling terrible and
that you have to tell her but you tell
her that the reason why you didn't tell
her is because you care about her and
you didn't want to lose her if she still
leaves you after that then you know she
was gonna find something right okay Jim
girl you know something I don't know if
I have time to read all of these I'm
gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] get out of here
here I'll be okay out this is the worst
thing ever I'm going to try to read this
quickly I already read bad when I'm
reading at a normal pace here hey Billy
cue ball a couple months back I started
going to another gym a town over for a
change of scenery
after a couple weeks I've run into this
tall athletic girl she didn't talk to
anyone and had that I'm not trying to
talk to anyone look going on because of
this me and virtually because of what
because of this and me virtually never
cold approaching a girl before I left
her alone over the next few weeks I
noticed she would be in my area a lot
and went moving between exercises we
would cross paths a lot sounds like
you're doing that [ __ ] whatever that
workout is CrossFit well you got to run
down the street you know look at us
everybody we're working out Hey look at
us you know leaving your gym and running
around a [ __ ] 7-eleven parking lot
and coming back we get it you're working
out Jesus Christ all right
over the next few weeks I noticed she
would be in my area a lot and when all
right I already said okay we cross paths
all right so I said [ __ ] it and started
talking to her we had a couple of good
combos and I eventually got her number
look at you you were in the game
we didn't text much which is fine
because I've learned that texting should
be mainly for planning meetups I still
tried a couple of texts convos for some
rapport since I'd only seen it one to
three times a week
sometimes just in passing now the issue
is every time I messaged her she
randomly stops messaging there probably
cuz you're bugging her at that point no
matter how good the conversation was
going or she's busy I didn't see her for
a week before I left for vacation for
another two weeks and no contact it's
been a week since I've been back and I
haven't seen her in the gym was
marginally interested
was she marginally interested or did I
not come on strong enough should I text
her again or just move on and wait till
I see her again well if you're still
into it just text us you say I haven't
seen you at the gym and what the where's
the harm in that
you know in this day and age you know
make sure there's a lawyer there when
you do it thank you who knows with the
the what the next [ __ ] thing is going
to be yeah we just I would text her and
just say hey you know back you know
would you like to go out sometime
gives a [ __ ]
[ __ ] her and her cold [ __ ] vibe just
say what you want to do what she wants
to do it go do it if she doesn't move on
that's it
easy one alright but I wouldn't question
yourself you know [ __ ] all that don't be
in your head don't be like Jon Favreau
when swingers you know that's what I
always think just never get into that
[ __ ] mode just you know it's normal
to be nervous both men and women when
you're dating or whatever men and men
women and women everybody included
whenever you get into that I would say
don't ever send a text when you're in
that mode I would sit down relax and
just think what do I want I want to go
on a date with this person well that's
what you ask him I would love to take
you out sometime see me a minute I'd
love to take you out sometime right
that's it what's she gonna say how dare
you [ __ ] asked me out she's either
gonna say yes or no okay and if she says
no who gives a [ __ ] you don't have any
regret yeah asked but if you don't ask
then you gotta be like I would all right
for some gone wrong this is the last one
and I'm done I recently visited my
friend at his big-time college for his
school's right school rivalry weekend
I'm going big time that's what they said
when I went to Notre Dame versus uh USC
and they were like big-time college
football speaking of a Notre Dame got a
big-time ass-kicking against Miami holy
[ __ ] the convicts kicking the [ __ ] out
of the [ __ ] eye like I still called
the Catholics and not the pedophiles you
know what I mean I mean not everybody at
the University of Miami you know has
gone to jail have been arrested okay but
if you're gonna call them convicts then
I mean goddamn it we got to go pedophile
with Notre Dame right it was a great
time and his school was one school one
and at the last second and at the last
second so the atmosphere is crazy later
that night I attended a party at the
fraternity he he is a member of anyways
we meet these two girls and decide to
tell him we were actually real real
brothers and we somehow tricked /
convinced these girls into having a
foursome how do you tell them that
you're related and that they want to do
it
tricked is a very dangerous world word
to use right now buddy
alright we all go into this room what do
you mean trick what do you do did you do
the old quarter hey I'll make a quarter
disappear hey where's the quarter is it
behind your ear here's my dick we all go
into his room and start hooking up and
since he had a large bed we had girls on
it and we're banging them side by side
doggy style after what seemed like a
while but was probably six minutes I
unfortunately released my champagne of
victory so now it's my buddy and both
the girls in the bed and I'm just in the
corner of the room I really wanted to
keep back in there but I knew it would
take a little bit of time to get back up
so I decided to look for something to
use to start jerking off oh god I found
out what turned out to be my buddies
contact solution and applied it and
started tugging and after a few minutes
of limp-dick tugging I started to feel
movement and thought I'd be back in the
game soon you're like an injured player
that went out for a play at that pool
moment my budding the two chicks oh he
was nailing turn around and face me and
catch me jerking off from their
perspective they think I'm jerking off
to them oh no when a reality of jerking
it so I can bang the second girl one
girl sort of freaks out I love that she
freaks out if did [ __ ] thinking that
she's having a [ __ ] foursome with two
brothers one girl sort of freaks out of
my buddy screams what the hell are you
doing at that point I didn't know what
to say so I ran out of the room naked
and just stood outside the door until
they finished eventually the girls left
and my buddies let my buddy let me back
into the room where he proceeded to ask
why I was jerking off to him
oh no he goes I tried to plead my case
and give rash and give a rational
explanation but he's continuing to be
persistent that I was jerking off to him
and
now he's being extremely distant from me
and has told all of our friends who have
constantly been berating me for jerking
off while my buddy banged two chicks do
you have any advice on how I can somehow
spin this story I mean at the end of the
day I did get laid - all right here's
what's hilarious but all it that the
woman gets offended like what are you
doing it's like what are you doing
you're having like a [ __ ] foursome
with two people that you think are
related and secondly I don't know how
guys do that I don't know how you could
bang a woman with your buddy next to you
also banging you know what I mean like
how do you block out the sound of your
friend like yeah yeah right next to you
I mean do you look at each other at any
point and like how do you not start
[ __ ] laughing I don't never
understood that yeah you probably should
have gone into the bathroom you probably
shouldn't have been looking at them I
mean - what you have here is a [ __ ]
hilarious story and I you know in the
spirit of the table all right when your
friends are giving you [ __ ] I would just
laugh you just have to learn to laugh at
yourself and just be like I swear to god
I was trying to get back in the [ __ ]
game just tell the story the way you
just told it to me and think that it's
[ __ ] hilarious
that this dude thinks you were jerking
off to him I would just laugh it off
which is how you get out of most [ __ ]
you know it's how Donald Trump became
president he just lets probably a bad
guy to bring up he's out there grabbing
[ __ ]
maybe like he said all this [ __ ] about
women no I didn't I said it about Rosie
O'Donnell not well you said it about
other women too and he's like yeah you
probably right it ends it it's when you
keep fighting it I would just [ __ ]
laugh it off I know it's tough at your
age but listen to it if you have it in
you to [ __ ] [ __ ] a woman right next
to your friend if you have the focus to
do that I think he can get through this
but dude you got it one hell of a
goddamn story that's a great story
so anyways alright that's it I have to I
got to get on with my day here thanks to
everybody who's listening to the podcast
thanks to the the Fox foundation the
Westside comedy club please go please go
out to the comedy club and thanks to
everybody on front runner that let me
have a quick little part in that thing I
had such a great time oh and by the way
guess what's out daddy's home part 2 I
was in part one you got it part 2 I
heard his even better
Joe bartnik Rose Bowl tailgate legend
told me he went to go see that he said
dude I [ __ ] laughed out loud like 25
times comedians don't laugh out loud
ever it's one of the one of the [ __ ]
I don't know it's one of the prices you
pay as a comedian you stop laughing you
just start going oh that was funny but
you never laugh you never laugh again so
definitely go check that out and who
knows who knows maybe you'll see a
familiar face in there
alright go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in
on you on Thursday